[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectated TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 6th of
October
my name is Freddie gray I am the deputy
editor of The Spectator and I will be
your host today
on the show we're going to be talking
about the Tory Party Conference which
you may have noticed was this week has
Liz trust managed to get herself out of
trouble with her speech I'll be joined
by James Forsyth our politics editor and
Katie Bulls our Deputy politics Editor
to discuss after that we will be
discussing whether trussonomics is
finished I'll be joined by Kate Andrews
our economics editor and the head of the
institute for economic Affairs mark
littlewood
we will then move into Global Affairs
and the terrifying story of Putin and
nuclear war I'll talk to Mark galiotti
and Elbridge Colby about the likelihood
of Putin's nuclear strike and what the
West response might be
we will then move to Brazil where there
is a very interesting presidential
election going on we've just had the
first round and we will have the second
round on October the 30th I am joined by
Andrew Downey who is in Sao Paulo
and lastly we will talk about cigarettes
and giving them up Rob little has just
quit smoking I'll be asking him why and
how
before we get started let's thank our
sponsors kinda called genuity wealth
management experience wealth planners
and investment managers who offer
unwavering support in challenging times
visit cando wealth.com for more
information
and while you're at it why not subscribe
to The Spectators YouTube channel click
the button the Buttonville screen to
subscribe and then tap the Bell icon to
make sure you never ever miss an episode
let's start with the big political story
of the week which was of course Liz
truss the state of her Premiership and
Tory Party Conference I'm joined Now by
our top politics Duo James and Katie
James
um Liz truss's speech yesterday uh went
okay there were no major uh mishaps it
wasn't a disaster
um which given the state of the
conference I think you'd probably say it
was quite a boon wouldn't you
yeah I think it was a relief for her
because nothing is worse at the end of a
speech than it was beforehand I think it
went down relatively well with the hall
uh I am with the MPS present but I think
this conference you can't get around two
facts one Liz Strauss has had to back
away from uh a big policy the abolition
of the 45p tax rate and you you can say
oh it doesn't it wasn't it wasn't gonna
it wasn't that big a tax cut in the
grand scheme of things all this is true
but let's draw some quality quarter's
decision to abolish it was meant to be
totemic it was meant to show that they
weren't going to be slaves to what they
see as a kind of Social Democratic
consensus and so the fact that they have
had to uh Retreat from that is also
Titanic I mean the other thing we saw
this week as well is is how
ill-disciplined uh the cabinets are it
was at times like the height of the
brexit debates in the Theresa May era
where kind of every half an hour cabinet
minister seemed to come out of a
different position uh with no so fought
to Collective discipline or or anything
like that and so I think it's I mean can
uh Liz trust reassur Authority within
her her own cabinet and her own party
and also you know the Tories throughout
this conference were behind by 20 points
plus in the polls is that going to get
better for them
Katie have you been struck and how with
your knowledge of uh Team trust have
they been struck by the lack of support
they have from even within their own
cabinet and certainly the broader party
I think there's definitely a frustration
in dining Street at some of the
freelancing by ministers at this
conference and so for example penny more
than in an interview
um saying that she believed that
benefits should rise in line with
inflation that is not uh you know that's
currently a subject of debate in terms
of what the government is going to do on
it all the indications the Liz trust
plans to actually uh rise in line of
wages instead so I think
examples like that have taken some of
Liz truss's team at back and it and is
just adding to this sense of you know
what does she need to do now to get grip
and I think probably from last week
going into conference I think there's
been a slow Dawning realization of some
of the realities of Liz truss's
political situation and because I think
when you're in Downing Street uh when
Parliament is not sitting when you're
speaking to like-minded people or just
your aides it can be probably a bit more
reassuring than perhaps the reality
outside the building and I think being
at Party Conference you know having to
do lots of media meeting with people
meeting of MPS means that um Liz truss
is now much more aware of the problems
for example strategy and I think it's
also why we did end up seeing that
U-turn because The 45p U10 if you were
looking for the most graceful way to do
that given lots of people are saying
this is not going to hold I think you
would have kick-started your conference
so the big sit down Sunday interview she
did with Laura coonsberg on the BBC
to say we're doing this and we're
plowing on instead it came you know late
on uh late in the evening once
conferences started after that interview
was only when they really changed Tech
and I think it does point to the fact
that it's taken a while for Downing
Street and the prime minister to get up
to speed with the problems they're
facing
James uh Liz truss was in some ways the
continuity Johnson candidate
um certainly the those closest to Boris
Johnson
um supported her quite strongly from
from the outset but in your PC suggests
that um even they may be turning is that
not right
yeah I think now on I mean for example
it's a small thing in the ground scheme
of things but I think it's uh several of
Boris Johnson's close allies expressed
disappointment to me that there have
been no mention for example of him in
her conference speech that she hadn't
gone out of her way to pay tribute to
him and I mean this shows how difficult
things are because you know they backed
Liz trust because uh they thought that
she unlike lots of other people running
in the leadership had had no part in his
downfall but now that she is setting out
a very distinctive far more uh
libertarian small state tourist view I
think they are they are turning lots of
things that they that he considers to be
part of his legacy
um she appears to be diluting and so I
think he is I think there is a there is
a tension there among among the
johnsonites
Katie isn't the bigger broader problem
for the Tories there's a lot of people
are already suggesting uh if you and
especially if you look at the polls
um that they are clapped out that
they've been in power for too long uh
the party is sort of seems to be eating
itself alive and no prime minister
um and it seems not there's trust uh is
able to bring them together
yeah I think that is a large part of the
problem we can sit here and say there's
trusted X wrong why wrong clearly
they're not so many budget I think I
think all involved now except with the
gift of hindsight perhaps listening to
Samuel at the time that could be handled
much better but I think also having
spent you know four days in Birmingham
this is a party which and this is not a
unique Insight lots of people have said
it to to me as I'm sure they have to
James you know which is looking pretty
ungovernable uh you have a situation
where there's lots of MPS that can't
quite decide what they want the party to
be you had Boris Johnson he tried to
occupy that Center ground within some of
these policies and at the time lots of
members are saying this is awful but not
being conservative enough you had a
Rishi sunak who was obviously making the
pitch for fiscal responsibility and but
then you have to say well that's not
going to be enough in terms of tax cuts
then you have Liz truss who is moving
the party to the right in some of those
ways and now that's leading to Big
backlash for members who's saying well
at actually know the voters don't want
this and you don't have the mandate to
do so so it's quite hard to work out
what exactly would unite the party I
think there was some hope in Liz trust's
team early on that actually just the
prospect of a snap election in a year
and a half two years time would be
enough to really make MP's work together
vote for you things I think the problem
is uh partly because the mishandling in
terms of the fiscal event you now have a
situation where the polls are clearly
pointing to something which if repeated
and and you can expect I think the
positive change to some degree broad
election
um but if repeating election would
pretty much be an electoral Annihilation
for the Tories and that means it's much
harder to convince MPS to say oh you
just get more behind the reforms that
are currently looking quite unpopular
that's what's going to secure your seat
and it means you're in a situation where
there's not really any good options
there's lots of people talking about how
long Liz trust can stay in position
there's not really an easy mechanism to
do that but more importantly there's not
really an easy answer as to what would
you know be better and have the party
unite James if the problem is uh much
bigger than trust and it's the party uh
what is the real issue there is it that
the ideology of conservatism is
conservative isn't an ideology I suppose
but is it that the the party doesn't
know what it stands for
um are there too many different factions
are the tribes too opposed to each other
I think it's two things one as you say
Freddie it's a certain level of
ideological confusion the Tory party
isn't quite sure what it believes now
and then I mean the second problem is
the party is becoming unwhippable
because there are so many former
ministers now on the back benches
because you know the toy party has not
only changed leader four times in six
years it has also changed the cast of
characters because there have been these
kind of purges every time a new leader
has come in which means that you know
you've got a lot of people who who
aren't prepared to vote through things
that they might not like because they
they aren't bothered about whether
whether they're going to block their
copy book with the whips or not because
they're not looking for a promotion
they've had their time in ministerial
office and so they are now much more
inclined to to to to Simply do what they
want to do uh and I think this is one I
I think this is a big problem and I mean
because as Katie said Liz trust didn't
seek to build a big tent when she put
together her government uh that that
problem has become exacerbated I think
ideologically the toy party has in some
ways become unmoored it is not quite
sure yet uh at the moment what it stands
for what it wants to stand for in this
post-brexit world
Katie uh do you think uh that Liz truss
has not had a political honeymoon quite
clearly she's been thrown in uh at the
very deep end and seems to be struggling
to swim uh but that she might have a
delayed honeymoon
um after this speech which does seem to
have calmed the waters a little bit
so I think honeymoon is probably the
wrong word in the sense I think she
might have a period of you know Karma
Waters than she's had the past you know
week or so
um but yeah still you know that speech
did calm nerves I spoke to MP's after he
said she should be given the time to do
this and I think interestingly lots of
MPS I've spoken to some who bet Richie
sunac were complaining more about
Michael Gove and what is he he is up to
you out of all his interventions on the
45p and so forth and as much as people
were complaining about Liz truss so
there's lots of anger but it's not 100
clear you know it's pointed in lots of
directions there's this big guy almost
blamed game plays out I think what is
tricky for Liz truss is effect the the
commons returns next week there's lots
of votes she wants to push through
supply-side reform that means quite
tricky votes on things like planning and
is the party currently in a position
where MPS are going to get behind her I
think this trust needs something thing
to refocus minds and I don't know where
she can get a political win from but I
think that the Fallout from The Not So
Many budget the fact there was
infighting at conference means the
speech did probably the the most it
could do
um but I think she needs something else
to say back me things will calm down
let's talk briefly about uh Michael
gobert Jones you mentioned him in your
piece I mean he seems to be a dramatic
figure inside the party no matter who is
prime minister and no matter whether
he's in or out of favor
um tell me what he's up to
so I think Michael Gove and Liz trust
you know there is both personal and
political animus between them
um if you think back to the beginning of
Liz Ross's career she was a junior
minister of Michael Grove's department
they were both reformers but she feels
that he's kind of lost his reforming
Zeal but he is part of this kind of you
know Social Democrat consensus at the
moment and has become kind of very Nanny
statish and very controlling he looks at
her and sees someone who he views as
more of a Libertarian than a
conservative and and I think he feels
that and this is what I think he kept
talking about the 2019 Manifesto at
conference he feels that you know Liz
trust doesn't have a mandate for what
she's doing how she's trying to reform
what what what what the conservative
party stands for and so he's just gonna
say his peace
um I I think that I think Liz trust
would have been better off to have to be
crude to have had Michael go inside the
tent pissing out rather than outside the
tent pissing in I mean she it would have
he would have been a perfect choice for
example to be Health secretary you know
it is still the biggest risk of the
Tories is that the NHS Falls over this
winter or next and if Michael gopher
prevented that from happening and he is
the most effective Department mental
Minister for Tories have uh that would
have benefited list Ross and if he'd
failed then his political career would
have been over and but I think that this
tension between gov and trust you know
this is this is going to be a running
theme of this government in the next few
years
Katie and James thank you very much
indeed
now is tristanomics Dead on Arrival I'm
joined Now by Kate Andrews our economics
editor and Mark littlewood who is
director general of The Institute of
economic Affairs Kate you write in the
magazine this week that you think Liz
trust may be setting back the cause of
free market economics which as we know
is dear to your heart
um why do you think this is so
so it's only been a matter of weeks
since Liz trust entered Downing Street
uh and already the rollbacks and the
u-turns that she's have had to make I
think are are really damaging to the
free market cause and I should say they
started before she actually won the
leadership race they started during the
leadership campaign uh when she picked
up the idea of Regional pay boards which
is a really good really sensible reform
when it comes to public sector pay it
would enable regions to actually recruit
more public sector workers uh that they
are in short supply of it would allow
for more performance related pay to
actually give people in the Civil
Service who are doing a fantastic job
more pay and she picked it up completely
on underprepared to defend the policy
and it was dropped within a matter of
hours and the thing about dropping
policy like that is it doesn't take it
off the agenda for the leadership
campaign it takes it off the agenda
probably for a decade and I think we've
seen something similar with the 45 P tax
rate you turn list trust is now talking
about Reviving it a you turn on the turn
but frankly it is so much harder to talk
about major tax reform and tax
simplification when UA haven't tried to
make the argument and B then go ahead
and you turn and show that actually you
can essentially be pushed into to uh
rolling back what you originally said my
concern is that none of this is helping
the free market movement it doesn't put
a good spin on the free market movement
it's killing free market ideas and
policies and don't get me wrong it's
fantastic that Liz truss has everybody
talking about economic growth now I'm
not saying that you know she hasn't made
some improvements in the few weeks that
she's been in Downing Street but I think
she has a real responsibility as
somebody who has always loved to
represent the cause to make sure that
the cause is you know is is thought to
be successful coming out of her
Premiership as well as the country you
know I think she has a lot of things
she's juggling here
um but it would be such a shame if we
got to the end of the Liz trust
Premiership and people actually had a
worse view of free mark economics
mark on paper Liz trust did look like
the the ideal iea Prime Minister but in
practice so far anyway things don't seem
to be going so well how do you feel
about trophonomics and how it's being
applied yeah yeah I've got a lot of
sympathy with what um Kate says there
because it seems to me that we've got
the most sort of free market leaning
government one could expect I mean you
know I would like the government to be
even more free market leaning than this
but if you were trying to construct a
government of of any set out of the 650
MPS that we've got in the House of
Commons this is probably sort of the
bunch that you'd pick to be most likely
in the free market Direction but I share
with Kate The View that the uh it's been
well to put it at its mildest and
inauspicious start so I'm in I find
myself in the kind of nightmare position
that we've got a Libertarian leaning
free-market-ish government who really do
seem finally to be sort of picking off
the shelves of the IAS and policy ideas
and implementing them which is what a
think tank would ultimately want but the
political execution has been absolutely
Dreadful and um if she makes a complete
horlicks of it which basically she has
so far her Administration has so far
it's been a politically inept let's be
honest about it
um then I share Kate's concern but I'm
going to refer back to one of my great
Heroes a former manager of Southampton
football club Nigel Atkins who said
control the controllables
um and I I don't work at number 10
Downing Street I you know have
absolutely no input on their you know
their comms plan or the sequencing of
their announcements so I I I feel myself
in the unenviable position where sort of
if you like the iea might get the blame
for anything that goes wrong or other or
the free market movement in general
without having any of the responsibility
over it but here's the kind of case for
the defense I guess let's assume that uh
Kate and I rather than being sort of
non-partisan keen free marketeers where
instead non-partisan Keen marxists
what would we have made of the rise of
geraldy corbyn to the leadership of the
labor party surely on one part of us
would have been punching the air
suddenly our faction on the left having
been doing nothing for decades other
than writing pamphlets that are small
people small number of people listen to
and making an occasional Splash in the
media suddenly we've got control of one
of the Great British political parties
but we would be similarly tearing our
hair out about how utterly inept and
incompetent the corbyn leadership was
even if it was ideologically aligned so
I do agree with Kate's criticism in so
far as it's a matter of sort of
political execution u-turns are bad news
um but I can't fix that bit so I remain
in the position of wishing the trust
Administration well broadly I haven't
agreed with everything it's done even in
policy terms let alone in execution
terms but we are where we are and you
know a really glum fact for kind of
libertarian leading free marketers to
conjure with is this is probably as good
does it ever gets for us
that is government it's a very neat
parallel because uh you've radical free
marketeers are sometimes called the
marxists of the right
um Kate I do Wonder thinking about the
politics reading your piece you talk
about how the there is a need it's
difficult to sell free market Classical
liberalism
uh politically it's a difficult cell do
you worry Mark ended on a glum note
there do you think that perhaps it's
just too difficult to implement proper
free market economics in today's
political world I don't think it is
because I I believe that so many of the
free market policies offered the right
Solutions and I think that recent
history proves that and I talk about how
Margaret Thatcher and Ronald Reagan uh
really
um got got into the details of the
public policy that they were trying to
promote they knew it like the back of
their hand and thus they were able to
make these convincing arguments but a
lot of it is counter-intuitive the idea
that you might lower the tax thresholds
and you would get more Revenue into Her
Majesty's treasury as a
counter-intuitive argument the fact that
actually using more of the private
sector to provide Public Services can
provide more Universal benefit is a
counter-intuitive argument and you have
to be prepared to make it I think what's
so shocking about the Liz trust
government so far is we know that list
trust has been in and out of the think
tanks over the years actually Penning
public policy under her own name one
can't say that she isn't familiar with
the arguments but it was so shocking to
me during the leadership election to see
her just abandon I think half of the
argument which is you know low tax great
growth great but you also have to get
the size of the State under control that
suggested to me not in an ability to
make the argument but an unwillingness
to that she knew it wasn't going to be
politically popular or maybe as I say in
the piece you know she had Amnesia and
it's you know it just fled from her mind
during the coverage years that you
actually need to balance the budget but
I've been really horrified to see so
much Applause around what was
essentially a heavy spending big stay
mini budget and she is billing this as
Classical liberalism she's billing this
as as the free market Revolution and
it's simply not and I think Mark's point
about Jeremy corbyn's a really
interesting one because as I say in the
piece you know on the free market side
we we often talk about how real
socialism has never been tried and this
is essentially the case that so many on
the left make you know well you know we
wouldn't have gotten the gulags we
wouldn't have had starvation socialism
wouldn't have failed if it had been real
socialism but you know these things went
to Rye um thankfully the stakes aren't
that high for us there's still consensus
in the UK that we want a free enterprise
capitalist country and so if things go
badly don't get me wrong wrong A lot of
people are going to get hurt but we're
not at you know that level of pain but
Liz trust cannot turn around and say oh
well you know my economic plan wasn't
really tried uh you know she asked for
this job it is a really difficult job
I'm grateful I'm not doing it right now
but as I said she has a responsibility
to do it better than she's been doing it
so far and I also think there's a real
responsibility for Mark myself for the
free market movement to honestly break
down whether or not her policies are
free market or whether or not they're
staying same old big spending big state
agenda and I actually think a lot of
what we've seen so far falls into that
ladder camp
Mark you spent some time with quasi
quatang at the Tory Party Conference
this week do you think the uh U-turn
um on the on the 45p tax rate was a big
mistake uh do you think they should have
stuck with it
probably yeah they probably caused the
you know they've taken all the political
hit without the win and again this is a
classic sort of example of the difficult
position that this badly run government
at least in its early days has put free
marketeers in because in the abstract
well not even in the abstract in
Practical terms I would like to see the
top rate of income tax fall from 45p to
40p but I've got to say it's probably
somewhere in my list of my top 400
priorities uh I don't I mean I'd like to
see it happen and if somebody makes it
happen I'll generally cheer them on but
why on Earth they pick that as their
absolute centerpiece either in political
presentational terms or indeed in
economic terms and I'm interested in the
second of those it's barely more than a
rounding error I mean I'd like to see it
happen don't get me wrong I think the
top rate of tax is too high I think 40p
is probably still too high if I'm going
to be honest so if I'm asked
specifically about that policy I say oh
that's good yes but uh it shouldn't have
been the priority in fact uh I at the Ia
was agitating for if there's any fiscal
room use it to reduce vat which also has
the benefit of being a
counter-inflationary measure you would
generally expect prices to fall if the
at is coming down
um so you're getting this difficult
position in which I was defending the
cut of the tax rate from 45p to 40p but
it turns out what the problem is is they
haven't communicated they were going to
do this to their own back benches in the
conservative party and they failed to
put up any meaningful intellectual
argument for it other than growth and so
I say that again growth you know they're
happy just to go to that they've got to
explain to people why they think this
would assist growth and they made a
complete horlicks of that I'll give you
a bit of a scoop here when they were
getting into trouble over this policy
but long before they abandoned it this
was still at the time where number 10
were saying this is going to go through
and any conservative MP who says
otherwise will be sort of thrown out of
the party you'd like to fight in
Parliament I put for them the suggestion
that why don't they run the Laffer Curve
argument why don't they say uh all right
well I know a number of people are
worried about this and I can understand
that that we would want some revenue
flowing in from the high owners we are
going to reduce it to 40p but we're
going to ask the office for Budget
responsibility over its first year to
measure what they genuinely think the
change in Revenue has been and we are
actually confident
um we think there is a very good
Fighting Chance uh better than 50 50
that revenue streams will go up
um as they did when we cut the 50p rate
to the 45p rate back in the day if they
don't if they don't go up if we find in
a year's time that we're two billion out
of pocket on the obr's forecast we'll
reverse the decision then our aim is to
get more Revenue into this Checker from
high earners and we think we will
achieve that through this policy and the
obr will Mark our homework I think if
they put that argument from the outset
or indeed once they were getting into of
trouble that would have prevailed it
would have been extremely difficult for
a grant chaps or a Michael Gove to say
oh no no I'm I'm not interested in
whether more Revenue comes into the
exchequer from the rich I'm just
interested in the virtual signaling uh
politics of having a higher top rate
they would have they would have won the
day but it seems to be their approach in
in executing policy or presenting it is
completely binary you either already
understand the free market case in which
you're probably nodding along with the
Prime Minister and don't if you like
need an explanation or you don't
understand it in which case you don't
really understand a word that she's
saying and not having had for 30 years
really elected politicians I mean only a
handful putting forward the case for
free market economics I think quasi and
Liz have made the error that it doesn't
require explanation that at least voters
on their side of The Ledger or swing
voters sort of intuitively get what the
the boundaries of the debate are and
they don't and if that failure of
explanation and education explaining why
you're doing doing something not just
for growth but why you believe this
policy will bring it about uh then
although they're 28 30 behind in the
opinion polls I could see that tanking
further still
Kate uh just quickly uh to wrap it up
um it's clear as Mark suggests it's
clear they've made a political horlicks
uh of the minute mini budget but
economically
um do you think we just saw a giant
freak out um in the media and perhaps in
the markets too because actually things
uh have stabilized the pound is now
stronger than it was before the mini
budget and uh guilt yields are coming
down they're calming down so I mean was
economically do you think you could make
the case that the mini budget was not
actually that big a disaster certainly
not the implosion of the British economy
that a lot of people made out well I
think anyone who was using the word
implosion or catastrophe at the time was
certainly over egging it that wasn't
what we were witnessing on the
spreadsheets it was a nervousness about
what they had announced and I think that
nervousness was well placed and indeed
seems to have gotten them to change
course especially on the spending cut
side and on the spending Ledger side it
was a reminder that actually you you
must count for what you're spending you
must account for what you're borrowing
nobody is expecting the UK government or
indeed any government to balance its
books this year or next year especially
not after the pandemic but what was so
shocking about again what was billed as
some kind of classical liberal
Revolution many budget was that it took
the I think faulty premise during covid
that governments can now spend whatever
they like and borrow whatever they like
and markets will be delighted for them
to do it and funded on the cheap and it
said no you know the the old economic
rules apply and you know you cannot
throw all of this borrowing and
day-to-day spending onto your agenda and
not get some wobble in the markets I I
was delighted in some respects just to
see that reminder being issued to the
government and you know this was
probably one of the least fiscally
disciplined announcements we've had in
the 12 years of this conservative
government I think it would have made a
Gordon Brown budget blush to some extent
because it it wasn't just oh you know
we're going to deal with spending later
it was this real assumption dare I say
even a hubris that they could just do
what they wanted and spend what they
wanted with impunity
um so you know it I I wouldn't have
called it an explosion to begin with it
was a nervousness and it is settling
down because the the rhetoric is
changing from the government at the ieas
and conversation uh with the chancellor
I think quasi-quartang couldn't help
himself but to repeat over and over
again that he respected the financial
institutions of the UK that he wanted to
get spending down and he wanted to
address that side of the ledger so I
think that's what's calming markets down
is their response
um but it was completely understandable
to me why we saw that shakiness over the
past few weeks and it's baffling to me
that Liz truss who has built herself
again as this free marketeer who
understands the importance that Mark of
markets and that markets work was acting
surprised uh I think that was probably
the most shocking thing for me
Kate and mark thank you very much indeed
let's move on now from Tori apocalypse
to possible Global apocalypse and the
threat of a nuclear war
and fears about Vladimir Putin's threats
to make a nuclear strike either on
Ukraine or further field increased this
week after images emerged of a Russian
train belonging to the secretive nuclear
division traveling towards Ukraine
I'm joined Now by Mark galiotti who is a
political scientist and a frequent
contributor to The Spectator and
Elbridge Colby who is a former official
in the U.S defense department
Mark I'll start with you in your piece
this week you talk about how the West
might respond to a nuclear threat and
I'm struck that in Western policy
establishment terms there's a lot of
talk that Putin is both bluffing and
that we need to take his threats
seriously
surely both can't be true which one is
right well I'm going to be very much the
academic and say well both are true look
on the one hand at the moment he's
almost certainly bluffing the very fact
that he felt the need to say that he
wasn't bluffy he's already something of
a tell
but that doesn't mean that he
necessarily will continue to be so look
this is very much an existential
political struggle for him never mind
Russia his own legacy and his own
political position are on the line and
with his annexation his room for some
kind of a eventual deal and a
renegotiation of what victory means are
very limited so I think the big concern
is that at the moment he's bluffing but
there may well come a point when he
feels that he's faced with a choice
between escalation and capitulation and
that he has no option but to escalate so
that's that and the other issue is look
by preparing now then we bring about a
certain degree of deterrence by denial
we actually make it less likely that he
thinks that shaking his nuclear weapon
at us is likely to get some kind of
political payoff so I think this is more
about being concerned because after all
we should never ignore nuclear threats
from a nuclear power
Elbridge there's been a lot of
discussion uh this week about whether an
eye for an eye approach uh if Putin does
indeed
um launch a nuclear strike is
appropriate uh the in Mark's PC details
How the West might respond and it could
involve
um a very substantial reaction that
doesn't involve nuclear retaliation do
you think uh a nuclear strike still has
to be kept on the table as it were
my view is not in response to an attack
in Ukraine I mean I I wouldn't
necessarily advise the the US government
or the Western governments to advertise
this point I think a degree of ambiguity
is important but
look let's be realistic I Mark probably
no I'm sure knows Putin's mind far
better than I do but I I have a pretty
sort of existential level of humility in
assessing what what he what he's going
to do and what the the Kremlin is going
to do I mean I think Mark put it well
that he is potentially in an existential
political struggle and I'll tell you
frankly that this is Ritalin of the kind
of scenarios that I've participated in
over the years where Russia does use a
nuclear weapon uh it's not it's maybe
not quite back again back into the wall
but I look at I look at a couple of
things I mean there's the the you know
predicament in which he you know
deservedly and laudably from our point
of view finds himself but there's also
the fact that the Russians have
something on the order of 5 000 or more
nuclear weapons as Putin himself pointed
out in many respects they're more modern
than our own uh certainly than the US
the British have modernized a lot of
theirs over the years
um and and the other thing is the
Russians have invested a great amount of
money and time into you know re
recapitalizing their nuclear deterrent
in the 2000s and afterwards so it's
including their their non-strategic
they're non-apocalypse kind of or at
least farther away from the apocalypse
weapons and that tells me that they
think they have some utility that's not
just you know foolishness uh they they
made conscious choice so I you know is
is it a one percent chance a point one
percent chance a ten percent fifty
percent I have no idea but but if it's
sort of above you know point one percent
I'm taking it fairly seriously
um you know my view is that we made a
conscious decision I think rightfully
that Ukraine is not a NATO that we
should support the ukrainians and that's
critical and we should continue to do
something doing so I think the the Brit
uh the Europeans should take a more
leading role in that effort because of
the necessity of the United States to
focus on Asia but I do think we should
continue to support the ukrainians with
weapons and so forth and Aid
etc etc but look I think very very
clearly and practically if there's a
large-scale military response even at
the conventional level to a Russian
nuclear strike I think we have to
anticipate that we will get into a
significant conflagration with the
Russians and the Russians don't have the
capability Clearly Now to fight us
conventionally so they I think unless
they are prepared to accept total
capitulation to Nato in that context
then I think we're looking at a nuclear
war
you do detail that what these the
response from the West might be that a
non-nuclear response that would never
nevertheless be devastating for Russia
my thought when reading that was if the
response is so devastating surely Russia
could just carry on
um with nuclear attacks and these would
escalate and we'd get into a very very
dangerous description as Elbridge was
just describing
yes that's certainly the risk but again
unfortunately once we've reached that
stage we actually have a pretty limited
range of options I mean basically we too
could we could back away and say
actually come to think of it Ukraine
you're on your own
which I don't think anyone is is
seriously advocating it's only at the at
the government level at this point or we
have to strike back in such a way this
is the problem though the art is exactly
in the calibration I mean in the article
I mentioned for example that according
to some German sources I was speaking to
Russian early warning radar systems
would definitely not be targeted because
of the fear that if we did that might
make a paranoid Moscow think that it's a
Prelude to launching strategic nuclear
strikes so again I mean I think this is
the interesting thing at the moment you
know we are all looking for our ways of
sort of calibrating little apocalypses
rather than allowing it to to spiral in
in into the big one but the point is in
a way we have to be making these
preparations in order to be able to
present a credible deterrent to
precisely any such Russian escalation
and this needs to be being communicated
very directly and clearly to the
Russians and you know as I argue in my
article we might want to be perhaps a
little less ambiguous than we've been in
the past about the the menu of of
different kinds of Woe that faces Moscow
in in these cases but when if and
hopefully never the push really does
come to shove on this issue what we have
to be is clear that there needs to be
some kind of credible strike back
because the point is it's not just about
Putin we are obviously concerned about
him and he is at the moment the ultimate
decider when it comes to to Russian
policy but there are many people around
him I mean even if he does decide to
launch a tactical nuclear weapon it's
not like in the films where you know a
person gets to push a red button he just
simply gives orders to his generals who
in due course will send orders down the
chain of command one of the things that
it will be useful for us to do is to try
and communicate also to the generals the
terrible costs thereof so I mean again
it is a ghastly situation to be in and
is unfortunately the reality of the
nuclear age something that we thought
we'd never really have to confront but
we are in a position in which we're
having to calibrate our deterrent strong
enough to make it look to Putin that
it's not worth going to these kind of
escalatory levels but on the other hand
not so overpowering that it looks as if
we're out to
force him into some kind of humiliating
you know defeat it's not like we're
going to be then saying and we want to
have NATO forces in red square and a
NATO flag fluttering from the Kremlin
you know they have to be the roots
whereby he can think I had been punished
this hasn't worked but on the other hand
making some kind of a deal now is a
better option than just simply going for
some kind of escalatory spiral that as
Albridge says you know could it easily
lead us to thermonuclear Armageddon
maybe if I could jump in briefly I mean
look Kissinger has a good line that the
arguments for a war at its beginning
need to look as uh the arguments for a
war need to look good as good at its end
as at its beginning and with all due
respect Mark I I think look I I think
there's a very good chance that that a
large-scale conventional retaliation
could lead us exactly to that I mean
what I'm really worried about honestly
is that we will slide into a very very
serious situation I mean we're already
in a very serious situation but a truly
grave situation without having fully
front loaded the consequences and the
risks Graham Allison had a very good
piece in the Boston Globe yesterday look
I'm not I'm not a favor of abandoning
the ukrainians I don't think that's the
right calling we should support the
ukrainians they may have to sort of you
know accept some of this realistically
but I mean the reality is that we're
dealing right on Russia's doorstep
obviously leaving aside the the
annexation of the of the provinces
something that they CLA very clearly
care a great deal about if you look at
the speech that Putin gave at the
Kremlin
etc etc obviously this could be bluffing
but we just don't know and I mean in the
conditions that we have always
understood this this is a very very
serious situation I think we should act
accordingly
Mark I'll let you reply though
yeah look I think the question that this
is a dangerous situation I don't think
that anyone would would question that
though I would say that I think up to
now Putin is demonstrating that he is a
rational actor he's a rational actor who
believes a whole bunch of deeply
irrational things but nonetheless this
is not a man who is insane this is not a
man who is willing to kind of go down in
some kind of global go to Dameron as
long as he brings his enemies down at
the same time and we shouldn't forget
that they themselves will also be having
similar conversations about how far can
they push and and what the risks are but
the key key point is that look there are
no good outcomes if it actually comes to
the use of tactical nuclear weapons by
the Russians you know do we respond too
easily do we Curson who quickly do we
end up actually
um giving giving way and forcing the
ukrainians to accept the price of our
safety this is why I think actually
addressing all these questions now
looking at the whole menu of options and
communicating the the kind of threats
that would face the Russians if they
went this far none of which it's worth
stressing involve NATO troops Crossing
Russian borders you know these are all
about long-range strikes to damage and
degrade capability they're not the sort
of thing that you can then spin as we
knew it the Russians want to the NATO
wants to conquer the lands of the
Russians so I think it's all all about
communicating this credibly in advance
to make sure we're not in this position
where we have to make these ghastly
choices can I just I mean the problem
Mark is that um the American way of War
which is of course NATO is sort of from
the Russian point of view is a Cadet to
the Americans is exactly to take down
the Russian sort of Aerospace and sort
of
um C4 ISR basically the the brain
network of the Russian military so so
long-range strikes are exactly the
precursor to what they what they what
they fear whether they actually believe
we will or not I mean it's it's going to
be very very difficult to equilibrate
and I don't think I don't think we need
to get to nuclear apocalypse for this to
become exceptionally damaging for us
what if we get into a Tit for Tat
situation of of
um you know discriminate strikes for
instance using long-range cruise
missiles with with lower yield nuclear
weapons on us and they're fired at you
know if the situation escalates they're
fired into European NATO because if they
fire at the United States that's
probably at the end of the escalatory
ladder for the Russians they're aware of
that but what if they go after military
targets for instance within European
NATO I think this is what we need to
anticipate and and there are some people
not yourself but prominent American
figures and I think European figures who
are calling for wiping out Russian
forces in in Ukraine well I mean that
that will that I mean first of all
that's that's a war between the United
States and NATO uh excuse me between
NATO and and Russia so I think we've
really got to be very very clear there
aren't any good options what I would
suggest just to be clear is definitely
upping the costs on Russia particularly
in the sanctions World politically uh in
terms of actually increasing support to
the ukrainians again with the Europeans
in the lead it really needs to happen
but I I think we've got to be very clear
what I'm what I fear is an analogy of
the Korea 1950 situation where the U.N
forces you know under MacArthur were it
went to yalu and dismissed Chinese
warnings I I could be wrong I I could
certainly be wrong they may decide to
eat it but I you know the thing is we
won't know and people are looking for
these indicators of Russian nuclear
employment and I think we'll be pretty
lucky if we see at any given time I
think they've integrated they have
nuclear forces are something they've
exercised and sustained they know we're
watching so they may want us to see that
they may not though it may be a
relatively short amount of time
you say you you uh you still want to
carry on supporting the ukrainians if
we're in a position then it seems to be
that we increasingly are where Russia
considers that is it it is already at
war with NATO and not just Ukraine
um how do how does the West possibly get
itself out of this situation without uh
increasing your dramatic actions and
possibly nuclear actions by by Russia
well I mean the Russians don't actually
think they're in a war with NATO I mean
the people who are talking about World
War III and stuff I think that's deeply
irresponsible that's obviously Russian
propaganda if they were at war with the
United States with NATO we would be
seeing it I mean there are submarines
operating in the Atlantic and so forth
I'm sure at any given time they can
really still hurt us I mean I I know the
Russian conventional military has
performed uh really poorly I've been
surprised by it thankfully for us all
but I still have a lot of respect for
their Aerospace and nuclear forces or in
their particularly their their sort of
long-range strike forces so they clearly
I mean their rhetoric is one thing but
they are fighting a limited War which is
actually fairly advantageous to us in
the sense that NATO is not directly
engaged militarily
um so I I mean I I we are not in World
War Three world war three would look
very very different trust me
uh Mark I wondered actually
um just uh well if I can carry on the
apocalyptic tone of my questions
um I wonder how worried British people
should be because Russian officials and
Russian media have suggested that uh the
the nuclear strike on Britain is quite
possible and durable how possible and
doable do you think it actually is
well I think we should stress that it's
not so much officials as kind of pundits
and Talking Heads and the usuals or do
you have little shock jocks we've been
saying this
and look it
Rifts to a degree the place of Britain
in Russia's geopolitical imaginary
um I mean back when I was was still
being allowed to travel in Russia
I was often struck by the degree to
which there was this sort of strange mix
of Extreme anglophilia as well as an
assumption that Britain was still even
after the great game has been a long
time ago still their most subtle and
devious adversary and I have to confess
that I found it quite Charming that
people think we matter quite so much so
in that context when they talk about
striking Britain it's in some ways
because they see us as both one of their
key antagonists but also clearly a much
softer Target than the United States but
the key things that I really don't think
we should be taking this particularly
seriously there is a whole almost genre
shall we say of
geopolitical oriented discussions on on
Russian TV that in some ways is more of
a kind of gladiatorial entertainment
than news night
and in that context yes we need to worry
because I mean unlike Elbridge I mean I
think the Russians do regard themselves
as being at war with the West it's a
it's a different kind of War it's a very
21st century War it's one that is
precisely being fought through through
economics and politics and law and
culture and disinformation and so forth
but
unless one is willing to discount the
rhetoric of all the key security
oriented leaders within Russia from
Putin to his defense minister to the
Secretary of the security Council and so
forth who all use the language of War
when they're talking about this this
confrontation with the West not just
with with Ukraine so yes they regard
themselves as being at war with the West
the collective West and particularly the
so-called Anglo-Saxons
but nonetheless
they are subtle and smart enough to draw
a distinction between a shooting war and
a non-kinetic political war
well as long as they stay in the reign
of hybrid war and all that they can call
whatever they want when when we when
they start launching you know attacks on
a strictly nuclear attacks then and I
mean that's New World War III to me
Mark Elbridge I think we'll end it there
let's hope that we don't have to have a
more urgent version of this conversation
in the near future
indeed
let's move now to Latin America and in
particular Brazil where we've just had
the first round of the presidential
elections and Yaya bolsonaro the
Brazilian president has defied the
pollsters and come quite close to his
rival Luis Ignacio Lula de Silva
um de Silva still has a slight Advantage
but going ahead into the second round
which will take place on October 30th
the race remains pretty tight
I'm joined Now by Andrew Downey who is a
long-term long-time Latin America
correspondent Andrew
um why did bolsonaro approve the
pollsters so wrong what did the
pollsters get wrong
the boss has actually got Lula's support
more or less correct you know within the
margin of error
um the big difference or the big
surprise was that the the pool suggested
that Lula might win in the first round
as you know Brazil's election is uh it's
uh you need a majority in the first
round if there's no majority you go to a
runoff
so there was a lot of Hope in the Lula
camp that he might squeeze past the 50
Mark in the first round and that was
really proven to be a fallacy
um
the difference between the two
candidates was only
uh
four percent which is you know next to
nothing
Lula had 48.2 percent bolsonaro had 44.3
it's for a 3.4 I think
um but the difference was was quite
small and was a lot less than what the
poles had suggested
and looking ahead to the second round on
October 30th Lula Remains the uh
favorite uh and in fact given that
um the parties that did uh came third
and fourth uh have thrown in their
support for
um uh Lula it seems quite likely uh that
it'll win is that not right
yeah Lula is definitely the favorite uh
in Brazilian history no candidate who's
won in the first round has gone on to
lose in the second round and look at the
who won in the first round has got less
votes than they did uh has gotten I've
got less votes in the second round so
Lulu only needs a couple of percent to
to get above that 50 threshold
um as you said Simon Tibet who was in
third place with five percent and
cirrogoma Susan uh sorry four percent
and uh Siro Gomez who was in fourth with
third percent they've both given their
support to Lula so everything suggests
that he should just get those those few
votes that he needs to get over the line
the only thing is that the momentum is
now with Boston arrow and he of course
is he is the president he has you know
discretionary spending you know he's
going to throw everything at at the
election that he can in the next in the
next four weeks to try and you know to
try and turn things around and it's not
Beyond the realm the possibility that he
will do that but Lula is definitely the
favorite at this point
and there are quite a few parallels have
been made between Donald Trump and
bolsonaro and certainly their movements
seem to speak to each other
um the the Trump team and bolsonaro's
team had connections and certainly the
language around this election has been
quite similar to what we saw in the
American presidential election of 2020
where both sides are firing allegations
of Fraud and rigging at each other how
nasty has it got and how much nasty
nastier could it get after October 30th
well I think the best way to illustrate
this is is with this two days after the
election and the main story was about
masonry Believe It or Not Freemasonry it
was a this crazy
um video that resurfaced of bolsonaro
meeting with Masons several years ago
before he was president and how this
this all of a sudden morphed into he's
the devil
uh Mason to the devil uh you know
there's a goat in the picture uh What
does all this mean uh Lula was forced to
come out with a an Instagram post and
say I am a Christian I believe in God
and the fact that this has been the main
dis point of discussion at the start of
the second round
just goes to show us you know how crazy
this is we're not discussing it
discussing issues we're not discussing
policy we're discussing these crazy fake
news all this information that's coming
out with both sides really trying to
hurt each other and to make each other
you know look bad it's not who has the
best policies and who looks good it's
who Luke's the worst uh and who really
is going to make Brazil suffer and
bolsonar has suggested that he will not
concede the election if indeed he does
lose the second round
um do you anticipate that he will try
and hold on to power
well everything suggests that he will
challenge the results if he loses
um he has said that there's only he only
has three options which is um be killed
be jailed or victory
so you know that's a bit of a you know
audience statement by by any man that it
means so the big problem will be for
Lula is that if if he does win and
bolsonaro does contest the election then
bolsonaro has a a fairly rapid uh
following and it's very possible that he
can put people out on the streets he can
block highways he can cause all sorts of
trouble and that would force Lula into
all sorts of negotiations he would have
to spend a lot of his political capital
in order just to ensure that he will
take power on on January the 1st and
that would be a major setback for him
before he's even started
do you think we're looking then at a
possible Civil War in Brazil I know
that's been predicted before and hasn't
come true but do you think that that's
the that's how dangerous the situation
is
a civil war is as a major it's a major
event I mean I I I I I I don't hear the
people talking about a Civil War I mean
I do hear people talking about you know
unrest and you know increasing
polarization the polarization over the
last four years here has been you know
has been as bad as anything we've seen
in the US or the UK or anywhere else
um you know a civil war would be a real
step a lot a lot further than I I don't
think people are talking about that just
yet
um but it really it really is clear that
both sides are are are are are are are
really uh uh the extremes that really at
each other's throats so you know we'll
see what happens over the next four
weeks in the next the next couple of
months and then of course the next four
years
well let's talk a little bit about Lula
because
um it's odd to Outside The Observers to
understand uh why he is so popular still
when uh as far as we know a lot of
Brazilians uh thought that his regime
was deeply corrupt when he was president
uh he was jailed
um He makes himself out to be a victim
of great Injustice but uh all of
bolsonaro's fans and certainly some
other Brazilians who still think that he
is a uh corrupt figure
um where does his support come from
well Lula you know has one of the has
one of the world's most incredible
political biographies you know he grew
up very very poor you know he he didn't
finish school at first he he he grew up
one of of I think he was eight children
um his father left him when he was when
he was young uh he grew up in the
Northeast with no you know with no
indoor toilet with no sewage with no
electricity and he pulled himself up to
to get an education he he was shining
shoes at one point to make a living and
he got a job and uh as a metal worker in
a factory he became a union leader he
educated himself and he fought for you
know he fought for what Brazilians
called you know the people you know the
poor people and that is is a very
attractive thing in a country like
Brazil and he did amazing things when he
was in power you know a lot of the
things that you've just spoke about the
corruption and the and the problems that
he faced a lot of that you know a lot of
that is true obviously
there's no denying that but a lot of
people feel a real uh
you know a real tenderness and a real
love for Lula because of the we he
fought inequality like no president has
ever fought inequality in Brazil and
inequality of course is one of Brazil's
biggest problems it always has been and
uh his government which was benefited
from uh you know it had a firm base for
another card those are the Social
Democratic president that came before
him he had he had kind of put Brazil on
the on the street and Naru he gave Lula
a foundation to start from Lula built on
that he was helped by high commodity
prices which which brought him a lot of
money and he used that money to to pull
lots of people out of poverty and that
is a that is a real incredible thing for
Brazil and a lot of people remember
remember that very fondly a president
who just looked out for them and that
had never really happened before
do you think that the suspicion on the
right towards this election is partly to
do with the scandals uh of Lula in the
past I mean I think it's the mental hour
Scandal
um where it was revealed that uh Lula's
party the work Workers Party were buying
votes
um of other parliamentarians
um and there's some doubts to whether
Lula was directly involved or not
um but they are seen as as very corrupt
are they not
yeah the big I think one of the ways you
have to look at this election is it's
it's anti-patista antipastismo against
the word it's those who hate the workers
party will never vote for the Workers
Party and those who hate bolsonaro and
will never vote for bolsonaro that's
kind of the the best way to frame this
because you know I have I have lots of
friends and family who will say you know
you know we don't like Boston Arrow we
think he's vulgar we think he's uncouth
we hate the way that he mocked people
during the pandemic but he's not Lula
because they see the corruption that
went on in the PT government as Beyond
The Pale uh and they are quite prepared
to overlook all the corruption that's
happened under the Boston oral
government but it's it's it's again it's
just as polarization it's people who
hate one side and who hate the other
side and that's really the framing of
this election which again is quite
similar to America isn't it
it's very similar to America yeah I mean
as you said earlier on you know you've
had guys like Bannon and you know coming
out and and Advising uh advisor
bolsonaro you had Trump last week coming
out and saying you know my friends in
Brazil you should vote for Boston Arrow
it's uh you know
is often referred to as the tropical
Trump
thank you Andrew we'll we'll end it
there but uh we will look with interest
into what happens uh on October the 30th
and lastly uh cigarettes ladies and
gentlemen I have to bring you these sad
news that Rod little are much loved
columnist has given up smoking Rod uh
you said that the nannies have got to
you and they've won and you've quit
what actually made you quit
well I woke up one morning a year ago
and decided I was never going to smoke
again and what I told everybody at the
time was that this was a glorious
Epiphany and a testament to my
extraordinary willpower but what it
actually was was a was a capitulation to
the forces of coercive control and
Conformity
because I mean there was lots of things
wasn't it I mean not least the fact that
uh
I was spending 800 quid a month on
cigarettes around about 60 a day
um 1300 quid per packet now you can uh
probably even Kate can do the maths on
that I would have thought
um
which is an unconscionable amount of
money and of course most of that isn't
on the cigarettes most of that is is on
this sanctimonious and hypocritical tax
which the government levies from us but
anyway it annoyed me
similarly I was annoyed that
at having to go on Long Journeys without
a cigarette and then being sort of
harassed when I got off a train to go
outside the station Precinct and even
further and further away from from a
station whenever I wanted to have a
cigarette to to leave a pub in the
middle of winter with the North Sea wind
uh buffeting my head while I go out for
a cigarette or to leave a restaurant in
the middle of the meal and what I mean I
suppose is that all these scumbags who
introduced these policies who demanded
these policies whether it be the GMC or
Ash or indeed to people like uh Matt
Hancock all of them
um they won they won and so I no longer
smoke well I've said I don't know if you
ever read Garson keeler's uh story The
Last smoker on Earth
I've been surrounded by the police I
thought when my mind's eye that was
often you yeah well well that's how I
felt and I and you know I mean I will
never smoke again because the habits
kicked and it's gone
um and it didn't take any time at all I
think that's another thing which is
which is part of you know the
establishment lies which is that it's a
a terribly hard thing to give up and not
remotely it was a it was a double mate
I'm telling you uh it it I I had slight
cravings for two days and then they went
uh and that that was it you didn't
mention it in the piece but um I think
you should have mentioned it actually
that um smoking once saved your life in
New Hampshire it did it did yes take us
through that story please
I was in New Hampshire
um uh which contrary to its state motto
which is Live Free or Die or whatever it
is is one of the least free states in in
the USA
um and we were staying in the
countryside in a rather agreeable one of
those white clapboard places uh in the
nearer forest and because you couldn't
smoke of course anywhere near the house
I went for a walk first thing in the
morning uh for my early morning
cigarette into the into the woods in my
black trench
coats and uh
uh only later did I find out that there
I was sort of slightly hunched as ever
uh with my cigarette it was only when I
took my cigarette out
and lit it
that the hunters decided I wasn't a
black bear and therefore
shouldn't actually be shot through the
head on what was the first day of the
bear hunting season and it was very very
close indeed it was only when they
thought hey that's a bear hey why is it
smoking uh that uh that I actually so
yeah cigarettes saved my life on that
occasion that saved my life on many
occasions you know they've given me
great sucker and joy and pleasure said
you like the you like the cough in the
morning you found pleasure in it we'll
decide you see I occasionally have a
cough in the morning these days but it's
just a kind of clear your throat anemic
little cough
there's no viscous liquid to it which is
which is you know I I found that there
was something rather
um rakish and and and loose about that
that expectorant of mine and I slightly
miss it
and your your drinking less too at the
same time you've reduced drinking people
say you won't give up one thing at a
time what's it quite the same time about
halfway about in uh April this year I
decided that because I was able to cut
out smoking completely
I would reduce drinking by about 90
percent
um simply because I could do it and also
because it would annoy my wife
um uh Alicia
who was approving of the fact I've given
up smoking but
a bit I'll see about it given that she
still does smoke
so I just thought yeah and that wasn't a
problem either
unfortunately I've put on a bit of
weight because instead of drinking a
nice gin and tonic and and lots of wine
I've been drinking Snapple and Cups of
Tea
um so so I will die of obesity and the
first four weeks after uh giving up
smoking I thought
I'm never gonna die because I've given
up smoking that is how deep the
propaganda went I I was soon disabused
of that notion by catching covid almost
immediately
you do believe that the the the theory I
think there's some data to back it up
that smokers do not suffer as badly from
coving I don't know I know it's not
quite that I think smokers do suffer as
badly from covid but I think uh it's the
case and it's beyond contention uh that
if you smoke you are far far far less
likely to get it and that's been born
out in loads of studies the USA China
France they actually started giving
nicotine Taps to people you know
um so there's no you know it's it's the
things they won't tell you because the
overriding messages that you've got to
give up uh smoking also helps in the if
you have Parkinson's for example now
there are a number of illnesses where
smoking is beneficial
um
but it's not something you're told
anymore because of the weight of this
this kind of uh uh
elephantine propaganda we get given
which which just obliterates everything
else well Rod uh smoking or not I hope
you live forever so that you can write
many many more spectated columns thank
you Freddie let's do my best
is it for this week uh I would like to
thank once again our great sponsors kind
of congenuity wealth management they
will provide you with the expertise you
need to build your wealth with
confidence visit can do wealth.com for
more information
also you should if you do not already
subscribe to our YouTube channel
spectator TV
um you can do that by hitting the button
at the bottom of your screen and then
after that clicking the bell at the top
of your screen that will give you a
reminder so that you never ever miss an
episode that's it for this week thank
you very much indeed
[Music]
thank you